oh carlson's found a new opponent wait
what how did that even happen
that's insane wow what was that game
okay so um yeah they just had 88 games
what i did throughout the match was i
opened up any like really cool moments
in new tabs
and i have maybe like five to seven
new tabs open of some of the best
moves positions maybe full games from
the match
some of them i don't even remember but
um
i think what we'll do is we'll take a
look um
because in in the nature of bullet chess
these games go really really quickly
so we'll see some basically slow motion
replays
uh starting with this game oh yeah this
game was like a full game
look at this game um we'll look from
ferrugia's perspective
so faruja played against magnus's
scandinavian
and basically what happened in this game
magnus didn't develop his kingside
his king stayed in the center and he
just got backrank mated
when his king was still on e8 and
previously got a pawn to e6
so in the moment of this game i i didn't
really catch how
russia got such a good position so we'll
just see how
that actually happened um
but i feel like between carlson and
frugia
they've probably won the most like
combined title arenas
on the chest i know hikaru doesn't play
on the chest but
it'd be cool to see him thrown into this
mix
yeah andrew tang is probably like the in
terms of mouse speed he's probably the
quickest which puts him in
um top five or top ten bullet players
i know he's crossed three thousand maybe
thirty
actually andrew ting might have one of
the highest bullet ratings
but these days there's a lot of like
grand masters who are being more
competitive in bullets
it's pretty cool what is this opening
black has nothing developed
but black's also up a night
but basically down a bishop in a rook
temporarily
so white just wants to mate along the
back ring
can you stop it he's taking time here
because
it's not clear how you stop it
what is this game he just resigns
how did that even happen so all looks
normal b4
i think ricardo played this move like a
similar type of move against fruija
beat him really quickly with it so this
is a gambit like
yeah giving away upon like getting some
weird initiative i guess b4 deflected
the queen from defending this bishop
ah then the king lost casting rights
so move 12 magnus still has all these
pieces on their starting squares
f6 so ugly bruises just saxon knight
i feel like he missed queen h5 stockfish
doesn't like castling
but he made it work
wait for it wait for it bam e6
and even though black is up
a full night
white is plus six because it's basically
impossible to stop rook b1 and rook b8s
so he played in that six most natural
move
and then after rook b1 he just resigned
stockfish even showing like its force
mates there's no way to stop
the backrank mate the king can't escape
the bishop is too slow to develop
like black doesn't even have castling
rights here
so this is actually a really really
beautiful finish
also thank you quadra spassky gifting
five subs really appreciate that
spassky may be related to boris baskey
okay so that was the first highlight
ferugia beating magnus in
21 moves with the scandinavian first
pawn gamut then p scan it and then
unexpected backs back rank
center king checkmate next game
um originally i was planning to stream
much later this evening but uh
yeah toggy alerted me carlson was
playing and had to
boot things up
wait what what what just happened
there's four queens on the board this is
so cool
i think black's winning four queens
after move ten i had a game once it was
uh one of the most viewed videos on my
youtube channel
i was like six queens on the board by
move 16
but this is wow he's gonna promote again
what is this or he's not queens just got
traded
but these queens still exist
there's some sort of like semi-slav
i don't even know the opening i'm gonna
have to go back and see how that
happened
so after all said and done black is up a
pawn
and now we're just getting in to some
end game carlson has excellent winning
chances
uh pass pawn up material
up on time yeah let's
real quick let's just see this opening
so this game
they played some line of the slav
lee chess calls this alakin attack and
then
just watch what happens so black attacks
tonight like counter-attacks
they trade knights they trade pawns
wait that didn't happen they trade pawns
and then they trade rooks and both make
a new queen
and apparently this line is probably
just waiting for plaque
according to the engine and the database
um but kudos to ferruja for going into
it just for the
the lulls i guess so four queens on the
board by move 10
um and the problem for white is that
black just strikes first
after here here c3 really nice move
carlson wants to make a a third queen
and then yeah it was just a really good
position
for black
um i mean white stayed alive but
they just got some end game so that was
probably like the coolest opening
to have four queens on the board so
early okay so two cool games so far
this next one
so again monitor has a few few
interesting games to cover
this looks really drawish but you never
know like in bullet it can
just come down to time who has better
stamina
um light is up a pawn now
we saw carlson win one of these optical
bishop positions earlier
but it's going to take a lot of work
because as black you just put your
bishop here and you wait with the king
i wouldn't be surprised if a draw is
offered
yeah i think you can just pre-move
ah b4
wait is white winning now wow
look at that move b4 i think that was
just a winning move
because you stopped this pawn you've
queen this pawn locks king is out of it
that's insane just move the pawn
oh it's still tricky though oh bishop
here is such nice move
because you prevent the king from coming
here but how do you advance upon ah you
win this pawn
it's still probably a draw but that's so
brilliant
to play b4 there
and now it should be winning
carlson's squeezing water from stone
just don't stalemate ah it's so nice
okay so this game it was a dead dead
dead draw uh black just had a fortress
like all black needs to do is
move back and forth and if white like
puts the king in some weird stalemate
you move the bishop back and forth
there's no way to win this even the
lights up upon
um computer agrees also thank you uh
thank you kwadra spassky gifting another
sub
and kyren eckert subbing with prime
okay so what happened in this game was
i mean both players had enough time too
but carlson was still playing for a win
and then the moment the bishop moved
oh actually the bishop had to move
that's actually really crazy i wonder if
the position should still somehow
objectively be drawn
but i should point out if the king moves
here
white white has this move and then
threatening mate so
that's why he moved the bishop and then
look at this move b4
allowing double on passant
you can only do one on bassan if you
don't know what anpassant is you should
google on passant
but like b4 looks terrible because
you give black a past pawn and looks
like black will queen
but the point is you stop the pawn
and you make a pass pawn of your own
your king's in the better spot
and the bishop is stuck on a2 so the
bishop tried to reroute
but this pawn is is really strong
and then it looked like it should be
winning for white but
then the problem was
this bishop was annoying and when white
advanced the king got in
and if you play this the bishop all he
cut always cuts off
the um the king and the pawn
but then carlson still found ways to
to play on because he took this and then
took this
i think it was still always a draw
until around here
i guess we can see according to the
engine because then white
was able to advance upon and then it's
winning because
uh light comes back and
yeah this is a really nice finish i
think farrugia flagged here
but black has to move the pawn and then
another amplison and then this would be
mate so yeah b4 was just a really cool
idea to
to just keep playing for a win
that's so cool again mother has so many
games to cover
maybe after this match we'll like do a
replay every cool moment i'm opening in
a new tab
and then we'll we'll break down some of
the best moments of the the match
the b4 was so nice because i thought it
was going to be easy draw
someone was asking earlier um
if i prefer knights or bishops
i guess in this game we're gonna see
which which prevail
knights do defend each other something
that bishops can't really do
on the other hand with two bishops you
maximize square control
but that might not matter because
bishops are only controlling squares on
the king side and this pawn is dangerous
queen side down to the knight queen b5
he was probably calculating g6 or i
don't know
it looks really risky now
it doesn't matter if you queen the pawn
if you're getting mated
oh cool defensive move also golda story
welcome
back good to see you shout out to gold
dust
hope you're doing well
wait do we have a gdt ah
okay gold story i think that worked
yeah i hope you're doing well
uh you queen with check but you're still
getting mated what is this
oh knight f6 the rook defends black
still might be getting mated here
blocks off a queen oh but
now lights up a rook how did that happen
wow and now it's a pawn race
wow
0.01 seconds what was that game
carlson was getting checkmated but he
was also making a new queen
and this is a time scramble where they
both had
like less than 10 seconds
eventually
computer says black's winning but yeah
it was just super entertaining to watch
in the moment
the queen here basically what happened
parusia won back
all material won the brook and then one
the queen
so carlson went up went from being up a
queen
to being down a rook
and like clearly the engine did not
approve of
some of their moves
look at engine evaluation after making a
queen oh it was a mistake for him to
make a queen
ah he had queen b1 check
queen b1 forcing the queen trade this is
why board vision is so important
you have to see your triangles
or at least diagonals queen b1 is
actually
like once you see it it's an easy move
because then you take and then the
queen's reborn
thanks for pointing that out yeah a lot
of blenders here
nice feature from lee chess like we see
a lot of
a lot of red a lot of blood a lot of
peaks and valleys too
or peaks and pits basically anyway
moving on like if you can play
fast and low risk um that's sometimes
the best strategy
and there's certain openings like king's
indian setup hippo
london for white london kali stonewall
where you can kind of puts out the
the setup and be okay
i think acaro wrote a book on this is
like
pre-twitch hikaru but um
at some point he he either co-authored
co-authored a book or he had a
ghostwriter but
there is a book with his name on it that
talks about like bullet chess strategy
also what is this opening blocks up a
pawn but
king is getting attacked
but white's underdeveloped this is
probably okay for black
are you going to play viewers and subs
today
oh um to be determined i don't know
we're gonna we're probably gonna stick
around and watch there is a prediction
going on
uh oh i see the comment from braden
um let me know actually feel free to
just say what the better prediction
would be but because a lot of people
have already voted
i'd feel would feel maybe kind of bad
cancelling the
ongoing prediction but feel free to
offer also what just happened so in this
position
who's black magnus is black magnus takes
a bishop
offers a queen train black is
is better he's up upon king safe
ferrugia decides to grab the pawn
acknowledging the fact that the the rook
pins this pawn
and it look this looks like a great move
but then
it's black to move
and find the winning continuation
and it's just such an unusual type of
tactic
where basically it's black to move and
win the queen by force
i know i already kind of spoiled it but
if there's anyone watching in the future
on youtube
you can pause the video and find the
winning move for black
and it's pretty incredible so i know
some people are saying
bishop h2 which is incorrect
because white can take with king
and the knight still defends the queen
the pawn still pinned
so before you take on h2 and good job to
most people in chat
you play rookie one
deflecting either the knight or the rook
it's so weird like
you put a rook on a square where two
different pieces can take it but both of
these pieces are helping
defend the queen in some way
of course if you take the rook take with
the rook the pawn is no longer pinned
and you win the queen and if i takes
with the knight
which happened the game then the queen
is no longer defended
and then this tactic works
so black did sack i guess the rook and
bishop but you win the queen and then
it's
an easier win so this should really be
turned into a
leeches puzzle if we use the engine
like black house to play rookie in one i
think
oh maybe oh there's knight b3 random
ah knight b3 with ideas to play rookie
one next but you basically have to see
this uh this idea together winning
position
whoa it's foruja thanks for reading man
i was gonna raid you but you beat me
you beat me to it shout out to ali reza
fruga
really really enjoyed watching the games
anyway uh
just to refresh everyone what i did
during the match was i i just opened
whatever highlights from the games in
new tabs
so i've been going through some of the
best moments either best full games or
best moves
or coolest positions what do you think
about practicing by playing glitcher
spots
i play maya five sometimes they make
strange moves oh interesting
yeah bots in general are
are still it's still a different
experience and like compared to playing
humans
but i get i don't think it hurts at all
and i've been meaning to do more games
against maya bot
i i think i played it once but
i would like to kind of explore it more
and see how
humid it actually is
also rocket 101 thanks for the bits i
see your question
if i ever plan to play over the board
chestermints again
um yeah i'm not completely retired from
over the world chess
but i haven't had a chance to play
any recently and hopefully sometime
maybe
later on this year when things open back
up
but i'm not really seriously pursuing
the grand master title
um like i mainly if i'm gonna play over
the board chess tournament i play it
just kind of for enjoyment
or play it for like travel opportunities
um
so probably once in a while
look at these look at this setup bishop
here bishops he won
oh queen h3 using the board geometry
or eventual like check and queen g3 very
nice
these pawns are too strong well you
can't take the knight because you get
mated
now the pawns are smiling oh knight c3
blocks the queen defending
what just happened there the pawns are
still strong though
no don't resign you know what he could
have done
so faruja won this game but i wanted to
point out that
in this position carlson resigned
i'm curious if imagine maybe fruit is
aware of this type of trap but
if i were white in this position i would
play king b8
hoping for queen takes pawn
just trying to simplify because you
expect this and then this and then it's
just an easier way to pre-move but uh
this is one of the traps that i like to
pull
um i guess every so often more and more
frequently these days
move i would play as king a8
and then more often than not black will
pre-move this move
and it can be a draw so i was upset
carlson resigned and didn't
at least try this this uh idea
wow another like g5 wait is this uh
oh hey it's a rosman almost a rosman
french
lovey has a video on this where he like
he shows the setup and
i think the only difference is levy
plays g takes f6 and not
not queen f6 but it's very similar idea
and it just leads to another like really
sharp
attacking position where it's
it's actually hard to do much on the
king side for black
ah but he's removing the bishop oh
that's so brilliant
wow beautiful move knight a5
um moving to the edge but unleashing the
bishop and threatening
not only the queen but threatening
maiden two
so if rook takes a5 there'd be a really
nice queen sack for mate
queen h1 takes and then mates
it was a cool opening i was like this
levy rosman style french
yeah i did make the comment and usually
lovey takes with this pawn but
the same type of idea to be encountered
the bishop and then storm with these
pawns
that was actually a really nice
illustration of how
black can win really quickly um so this
position white is losing the queen or
getting mated
so out of all these moments i feel like
the most amazing highlight was this b4
move even though like the position was
still drawn
though the fact that carlson actually
managed to play from for a win
from a seemingly dead position which was
really incredible
i mean the four queen game was also
really cool
like this uh this crazy opening
so definitely some great chess
entertainments